three associates main associates he has
in the firm to do for them plus dr
kissinger makes money as a uh on boards
of directors he makes money uh for his
speaking fees he charges up to 35 000 of
speech and so it all adds up to quite a
lucrative uh post-government work
two of the people that used to be in
kissinger
associates brent schoff and larry
eagleburger are at the prime positions
in foreign policy in the bush
administration is there any kind of a
back and forth between all those people
now
well he's still in touch with uh
schoolcraft and eagleburger and they're
both uh still uh supporters of kissinger
and they're the interesting thing is
their ideology their sort of realism
their notions of balance of power their
rail politique that you see in both
lawrence eagleburger the current acting
secretary of state and brent scowcroft
the national security adviser i mean
they don't they not only worked with
kissinger and kissinger associates but
they go way back lawrence eagleburger
was kissinger's right-hand man his
personal aid in 1969 when kissinger
first became national security advisor
for president nixon and likewise brent
scottcroft became
the deputy national security adviser in
1972 or 73 so they go way back with
kissinger and they share his philosophy
of the world which is one of
understanding balances of power
realizing that power rather than
sentiment or morality or human rights
determines the way the world works and
an understanding that america has
certain interests and you have to pursue
those interests in the world sometimes
with a cold and calculating sense of
realism ross perot has a little book out
that's number one the best sellers list
of the paperback new york times and one
of the proposals he makes in there is
that no one working in government or
certainly in the white house should ever
have contact with foreign governments
once they've left government he says
this has bankrupt our system
uh what would happen to henry kissinger
if he wasn't allowed
technically he wouldn't be in too much
trouble he does not lobby on behalf of
foreign governments
if you look at the spectrum of influence
peddling in washington it's not a very
honorable tradition but it's an old
tradition in washington on the one hand
one into the spectrum you've got mike
dever say who the minute he leaves
government pretty much cashes in on his
connections as quickly as possible and
ends up in legal trouble for it on the
other end of the spectrum you have such
a venerable statesman as uh even clark
clifford or you know people like that
who make uh influence peddling seem like
an honorable uh a thing kissinger is
somewhere in the middle
and i say that because he did not lobby
the us government for four or five years
until after he left office still he does
not do any direct lobbying with the
state department or the executive branch
he's not really a lobbyist thirdly he
does not represent foreign governments
or any government entity what he does is
he represents corporations he serves as
an advisor and a strategic adviser to
them he doesn't lobby for them in front
of the us government but he helps them
get contacts overseas understand foreign
governments understand what investments
they might want to make in indonesia who
they need to talk to that sort of thing
so i think under the ross perot
i haven't i'm not sure of all ross
perot's rules that he would set up
kissinger would squeak by i do think
that it does present some conflicts of
interest when a guy goes from government
to out of government and appears to be
cashing in on the connections he made
and for that matter in kissinger's case
somebody who serves as a commentator who
is paid by
was paid by abc and then nbc as a
commentator now on the board of cbs
appears on cbs writes a newspaper column
when he's writing say a newspaper column
or appearing on the news saying we
shouldn't impose sanctions on china
after the tiananmen square massacre it
would have helped if he would have said
and by the way i represent arco which is
doing an oil and gas exploration
business in china i represent h.j hines
which is trying to open a baby food
factory in china
i've formed a group called china
ventures with coca-cola which is another
client and a few other clients that are
looking to do ventures in china and he
could say and i think he'd be right to
say it'd be truthful if he said my
opinions about china aren't influenced
because i have these clients there
as winston lord one of his great
supporters and aides said uh and i'm
sure kissinger didn't like the way he
phrased it but it's true he said henry
kissinger does not need a penny
of financial interest in orders to
support repressive dictatorships around
the world he does it naturally so i
think he probably would have felt the
same way about china if he didn't have
these interests but you get into an
appearance of a conflict there when
you're going in and out of government in
and out of commentary in and out of
working for private corporations it
would help to be a little bit more open
than he is and a little bit more
forthright than he is about what his
various interests are if we wanted to
hire him how much would it cost us let's
say we had a little company
no i mean you know the two of us we had
a little joint deal a lot about if we
had a if we had a normal corporation
he would charge about 250 000 just to be
on retainer for that we would only get
uh
three or four briefings a year in which
he and one of his assistants came and
said okay the brian lamb walter isaacson
corporation wants to open a copper mine
in indonesia here's a briefing on what's
happening in the south pacific and in
asia and what's happening in indonesia
the trends you should worry about that
sort of thing now if we decide well we
need a mineral concession in indonesia
the way freeport mcmurran did a few
years ago and we said to him could you
come help us set that up he'd say sure i
know the people in indonesia and he
would fly with us perhaps if we
you know were able to talk him into it
like he did for the chairman of freeport
mcmahon you fly into indonesia and he
would introduce the corporate leaders to
the finance minister the prime minister
and other important figures in indonesia
and for that we'd pay about a hundred
thousand dollars per month of his time
extra
and uh
when he does this what goes along with
it
in other words
you said that when he got out of
government one of the first things he
did was set up a security unit of five
people
well i mean
what goes along with it is first of all
the name henry kissinger if you're a
company like ours say our new company
that you and i have formed and we're not
very well known in morocco or in
malaysia or indonesia or singapore if we
have henry kissinger acting as our
consultant we get
we get entre into the top levels of
government also
you get the strategic insights i mean he
is a brilliant man i i know that
my book has been interpreted as being
critical of him and he certainly thinks
it's far too critical of him but i hope
i also display or show
put on display his ability to understand
linkages in foreign policy for example
how something you do in china might
affect the relationships you have in
malaysia or how
dealings in the middle east might affect
your ability to do similar dealings in
eastern europe what i meant by going
along was do you have to supply an
airplane for him
and you have to does he have his own
security and does he travel like he used
to when he was secretary you know he
doesn't like to uh give up the perks
that he had when he was secretary of
state there are certain people who as
soon as they leave office they retire
back into
that semi-obscurity that is the luxury
of people who have already been famous
and they get to go into restaurants
unnoticed they fly commercial that sort
of thing henry kissinger does not like
to fly commercial he does not like to
enter restaurants unnoticed so among
other things if he's going to do
something for us in
indonesia
he's going to want to borrow the
corporate jet he's going to want to be
flown around he has three or four
security guards at all times which helps
i mean not only
does he have to worry about his own
security somewhat but anybody who enters
a meeting with three security guards two
preceding him and one coming after
sort of enters with a bit of a splash
you notice that henry kissinger has
arrived and in manhattan it means you
don't have to wait at the bar for a
table at a fancy restaurant if your
security guards are coming in with you
so he likes to travel with all the pomp
and circumstance that is befitting the
secretary of state
and i think that adds to his aura i mean
one thing people ask me when we talk
about kissinger is why is it 15 years
after he left office he's still a larger
than life personality he's still
somebody who's on all the talk shows and
he's on mcniel there or when he enters a
restaurant or when he
speaks he still commands a great
awe as well as uh animosity i mean he
arouses strong emotions unlike say cyrus
vance or edmund muskie
or you know other people have been
secretary of state
and i think the reason is he works at it
he works at keeping his celebrity aura
at keeping his image high and that comes
with flying around with retainers and
security guards and being tightly
scheduled and making sure you're on tv
all the time so uh i think he tends to a
celebrity in this media age by the way
you know you look at c-span and
networks like this that have sort of
created a new media age he has learned
one of the true secrets of the media age
because all of us knew that if you're
powerful it translates into celebrity
what he realizes it works the other way
if you keep your celebrity or if you're
a celebrity it translates into power
because people are more interested in
what you say if you're a celebrity you
can command a higher speaking fee you
can command a higher consulting fee and
when you arrive in indonesia or india or
egypt or morocco it's more likely that
the prime minister of the king is going
to want to call you in and have you in
for lunch if you're a big celebrity so i
think that was the secret he understood
about the media age how irritated is he
about this book
well
um
he's upset about the portrayal of his uh
personality the fact that his methods
were kind were secretive that he had a
reputation for being duplicitous as a
secretary of state and these all come
from the tales in the book
i think that he's very upset about that
i assume he's not too upset about the
fact that um
uh that he's not too upset about the way
i present his foreign policy because i
think his foreign policy especially in
the middle east they taught with the
soviet union the opening to china were
all brilliant moves that helped
establish america's uh role in the world
after vietnam so he's not upset i don't
think with the policy in the book one of
his good lines if i may paraphrase it is
when asked about the book he says well i
hate the book but i like the title
by the way there was another book called
kissinger yes marvin calib and bernard
cab did a book in 1973. that was before
watergate and before nixon resigned so
it came out kind of early this was about
20 years ago and it's a favorable book a
sympathetic book to kissinger but also a
very good book one that's a very
thoughtful book how long did you work on
this
about seven years um
getting back to uh whether he likes or
not he he did get very mad at william
highland as you may have heard
bill highland was one of his longtime
aides
and a very close friend and supporter of
kissinger's and uh highland retiring now
as editor of foreign affairs by the way
this is anwar sadat not bill highlands
yeah right
but anyway um when uh hyland's
retirement party kissinger was supposed
to be the speaker a week ago
and when highland gave the book a good
review my kissinger biography a good
review on foreign affairs
kissinger backed out and got very angry
at him so i think he's angry about the
book but partly if i may say so
i think if he read it carefully
and if he weren't quite so thin scanned
and he certainly admits to being thin
skinned i mean he's notoriously so and
jokes about it
uh he would realize that the book is on
balance favorable to much of his foreign
policy but at the moment i think he's um
pretty angry about the book when you
decided to do this seven years ago how'd
you go about it
well first of all i
had done a book with a friend of mine
called the wise men which brought us up
to the vietnam period that was about an
earlier group of statesmen d natchez and
aval harriman in that crowd
so
i decided i wanted to take it into the
vietnam period and i wanted to uh use
kissinger as the most complex brilliant
devious uh interesting intriguing
character we had through which you could
see vietnam dayton and that period in
our foreign policy so i wrote him a note
dr kissinger had written some nice
things about the wise men i wrote him a
note saying i'd like to i'm about to
embark on a biography
of you
and he expressed no real enthusiasm he
said go ahead if you want and i'm not
sure i'll cooperate
uh but i knew that i couldn't let him
have the right to determine whether or
not i did the book or let it be an
authorized book where he had some
control over so i embarked and just went
ahead and started doing the book i
interviewed a lot of his friends
interviewed his family members
began gathering papers and documents
interviewed people who were in
government with them and after a while
he became more and more willing i could
sense to talk
it is a subject i may say that's quite
interesting to henry kissinger that's
henry kissinger
and so after a while
it became easy to get interviews with
him in fact he was quite
eager to talk because he loves to
explain his side of the story he likes
to try to convert his critics he likes
to try to woo
both
adversaries and allies to charm and he
loves talking about and justifying what
he did in government so
by the time i really got rolling on the
book i was able to talk with him
i guess close to two dozen times and
even sometimes late at night i'd get a
phone call because he would hear that
i've interviewed um
i think it started when i interviewed
arthur schlesinger about
whether or not tenure got whether
kissinger got tenure at harvard right
away why he was delayed a bit for tenure
i got a call from dr kissinger at one
point started saying uh arthur
schlesinger does not understand the
tenure system at harvard i was not
seeking tenure that year and uh so he
you know he would find out what
what avenues i was pursuing and often uh
give me a call to set me straight how
old is he uh kissinger turned 70 in may
and how active is he today oh very
active he's scheduled months and months
in advance he has that that sort of
bustling air of impatient that in
patience that very important people have
around them uh his if you you know he's
scheduled hour by hour you know through
the next couple of months he's always
too tightly scheduled and he's always
dashing around from a business meeting
to some social function to some gala
party
uh to some visit to some foreign
minister
travel plans and so he's very very
active and um no sign of slowing down
you list everybody that you interviewed
150 interviews
and the names go all the way from uh
benazir bhutto to jill st john that's
right and richard nixon to win vancouver
of all those 150 and it's listed in the
back we'll show the audience what it
looks like
who do you remember the most oh
interviewing richard nixon was the most
interesting bit of it i had a couple of
informal sessions with richard nixon
before he granted me a full-fledged
interview what does that mean informal
well i went over to his office or to his
house in new jersey we'd sit around
talking it would not really be on the
record
at one point he was excerpting his own
memoirs and i was working on that a
little bit another point was just a
dinner where he was talking and you
could tell this ambivalence he felt
towards kissinger i mean he's a man who
admires kissinger's mind enormously but
is very wary of kissinger's personality
and very jealous of the acclaim henry
kissinger got for things that nixon
feels was
should you know the credit should go to
nixon and so he would he would all of
his sentences nixon sentences about
kissinger would have spent on them if
you know what i mean he would say well
i'm not one to say that henry kissinger
is paranoid but and some people do of
course say he's paranoid there's nixon
talking but and then he would go on to
tell some tale about kissinger doing
something or kissinger losing his temper
but he was always admiring of
kissinger's mind and when i did my
formal interview i was there
and he said do you tape your interviews
i said no i take shorthand pretty
rapidly and it's easier for me than
taping and he said uh he pulls out a
little micro cassette tape recording he
says i hope you don't mind but as you
know i like to tape things i thought he
was kind of joking because the white
house tapes what got him in trouble but
he puts a little tape recorder there and
wants to tape the interview about half
an hour into it the tape gets kind of it
runs out and he's trying to turn it over
and it gets stuck he's kind of all
thumbs with his little micro cassette
and finally he says i was never very
good at taping things i was you know so
i looked up and started to smile
thinking he was making a joke but he
seemed serious about it
he said but he was a very i shouldn't
make fun of the president president
nixon very interesting guy very sharp
very good memory of exactly the balances
of power they created why they did
things and uh
and although it was exciting to
spend time with richard nixon the most
important thing was truly trying to
understand
the basis for this triangular diplomacy
between the soviet union you know dayton
with the soviet union on one hand
opening to china playing the two off
against each other seeing how that would
affect vietnam if you play china off
against the soviet union and how america
could retain a role in the world so to
hear him talk about that was very
interesting i know if you notice it but
there are very few
pictures of
mr kissinger and mr nixon together in
here
oh really uh there are a lot there there
exists many such pictures i think
there's one of them there in the
executive office building hide away
there is that but you know there's no
none of those tight up close shots
well and the executive they used to sit
in that room and that's the hideaway
office across the street from the white
house and the executive office building
and that's a very typical scene there
because nixon would sit there with his
feet propped up and he'd take a yellow
legal pad
and make little notes and he would spend
hours just ruminating about the world
and one of nixon's strengths as well as
his weaknesses was that he would love to
circle around a subject for hours and
take different angles on it and of
course that was bugged that room and the
white house tapes caught him in that
room many times and i guess he forgot
the tapes are on but it was in that room
where he was ruminating about what to do
about the white house burglars at one
point now with kissinger but that's what
got him in trouble because he said well
we could pay them hush money but that
would be wrong you remember that scene
well that was typical of nixon to sort
of look at it from this angle look at it
from that angle and what kissinger would
have to do
is hear nixon talk about all the
different angles of foreign policy they
could do and figure out which would be
the most sensible to pursue because
nixon would almost throw all these ideas
up into the air so they would sit in
that room for hours just uh sort of
figuring out what would happen what
would china do if we did this with the
soviet union how would the north
vietnamese react or how would moscow
react if we started bombing hanoi right
before the summit in moscow and you know
they would they would they would
sort of co-conspirators as they sat
there in that room and figured out
foreign policy also very secretive as
they sat in that room they cut out the
state department they cut out the
defense department from all their
deliberations and
if you look at the
opening to china it was done without the
state department even knowing it was
kissinger's secret trip if you look at
the paris peace talks on vietnam
kissinger was handling those secretly
behind the backs of the state department
that was conducting the real
negotiations or the official
negotiations state department didn't
even know that kissinger was doing this
likewise with the arms controlled talks
uh with the soviet union and likewise
with the secret bombing of cambodia so
you'd have nixon and kissinger sit in
the office there and make all of these
plans and keep them keep the rest of the
government in the dark
you leave us with the impression in the
book that you may have the
fullest account written
of that
famous scene first written in the
woodward and oh yeah the final day
something day's book
supposedly mr kishner and mr nixon got
down their knees and prayed and all that
how did you put that scene together well
there are uh only two major participants
in that scene dr kissinger and president
nixon and both are uncomfortable talking
about it but i raised the issue and
went through the scenarios and got their
virgins uh to the extent that they were
willing to talk but one interesting
thing about that scene and woodward and
bernstein got it basically right
that
struck me as i was doing the research is
how it leaked out
and what happened was after nixon and
kissinger have talked for about an hour
in the lincoln sitting room and nixon's
going to resign the presidency the next
day and nixon asked kissinger to kneel
down and pray with him and they do and
they pray and nixon cries
and kissinger tells him that he'll be
remembered better by history than he is
by contemporaries
well what happens is drenched with sweat
as his cert choked
so
kissinger goes back to his office in the
west wing of the white house
and they're waiting for him we've just
talked about these two men brent
scowcroft and lawrence eagleburger two
of his closest aides and they're waiting
for they know that kissinger has been
summoned over to the executive mansion
and they're waiting for him to get back
to the office in the west wing so he
gets back and starts to retell the tale
and then the private phone line from the
president rings on kissinger's phone
now kissinger
somewhat secretly was taping every phone
conversation that came into his office
and overnight a battery of transcribers
would come in and transcribe those phone
conversations and he kept records there
was also a dead key so somebody else in
the office if he wanted them to could
pick up the phone and listen in and you
wouldn't hear the click because it was
just a phone you can listen in on and
didn't make any noise so the phone rings
uh unbeknownst or they weren't thinking
about it but automatically the tape
machines go on and uh eagleburger picks
up the dead key
and listens in and nixon
the dead key is where you pick up an
extension phone and you can listen in on
the conversation without making a sound
it doesn't click so it allow it was just
really an extension phone that allowed
eagleburger to listen in
any and nixon says to kissinger please
don't tell them what just happened don't
tell them i was weak don't tell them i
cried
and kissinger says if i ever speak of
this scene i will speak of it in terms
of respect which by the way kissinger
does speak of nixon in terms of respect
about this scene
so
eagleburger has it and then
the next morning skocroft comes in and
they're the tape recordings of this
whole conversation as well as a
transcript of them and i interviewed
general scopecroft about this and he
said that on kissinger's authority he
destroyed those tapes and got rid of
those transcripts so eagleburger
scowcroft kissinger and nixon all sort
of knew about this scene
and that's at least how i tried to piece
it together for the book let me ask you
about uh connections and networking and
all that
basically right here where you're
sitting
we take calls and have taken calls since
1980 and a day or let's say a week or
two can't go by without somebody calling
up about the conspiracy theories of
foreign policy in this country and all
the connections so as you started
talking about these different
institutions i wrote them down kept
pulling them out of the book and i want
to ask you about the connections
council on foreign relations
what does that have to do with henry
kissinger
well
kissinger is whenever you have the
people call in and talk about conspiracy
theories or whatever and i say when i
used to be on the campaign trail you get
these leaflets and they all have arrows
and exclamation points and the
connections between various institutions
and henry kissinger and nelson
rockefeller and david rockefeller are
always sort of at the center of it the
council on foreign relations is really
just a discussion group and club
in new york city founded about 70 75
years ago to discuss foreign affairs
it's largely funded by the old boy
establishment network of uh
the foreign policy uh elite in the east
coast uh partly john mccloys and the
rockefellers and that sort of thing is
not an insidious institution it's a
perfectly respectable place i guess it's
only drawback is it's occasionally quite
boring if uh people drone on and on but
it's not some conspiracy or the heart of
some conspiracy to control the world
what it is is internationalist
foreign policy establishment a lot of
bankers so if you distrust the east
coast foreign policy establishment and
international banking you would distrust
the council on foreign relations but
it's not part of an evil conspiracy
henry kissinger got a start there to
some extent he was a
graduate student at harvard about to
become an assistant professor at harvard
he takes some time off goes to the
council on foreign relations to run one
of their study groups the study group is
on nuclear weapons and foreign policy
david rockefeller a lot of other people
are involved he writes a book on it
nuclear weapons and foreign policy
that's published by the council on
foreign relations becomes a best seller
it helps redefine our thinking about
nuclear weapons and how they affect the
conduct of foreign policy after that he
becomes associated with the rockefellers
and works for nelson rockefeller right
after working at the council on one of
nelson rockefeller's critical choice
series where you know rockefeller would
gather thinkers to think about you know
the choices facing america so he became
connected to nelson rockefeller and to
the council and through them i guess the
next group you might mention would be
the trilateral commission right are you
a member of the council on fireworks
yeah so i've been a member i am a member
of the counseling family and how does
someone like you become a member oh they
they picked some young people to i was i
work at time magazine i cover foreign
policy uh they start off by giving term
memberships to younger people and then
eventually i was elected a member
i think this membership of the council
spans a huge spectrum that people on all
sides of the spectrum they're young as
well as old i think the one connective
tissue i may say so is it is sort of an
internationalist foreign policy
establishment body
uh is there one thing that everybody
that comes together usually believes in
no i mean i'm not
very favorable to henry kissinger
but he's a member i'm a member i've i
don't think i guess i've seen them there
once in my life it's thousands of
members and you go
to a
particular evening or a particular lunch
where they're having
you know the japanese foreign minister
be a speaker and maybe a hundred people
will go out of the thousands of people
who are members so you don't really know
it's not like a club in which you know
most of the other members
uh
and so there's no connective tissue it's
not like you all have to subscribe
everybody has to subscribe to a certain
theory of government how do you get
selected for it
they have uh they elect about i don't
know how many they elect i'm not i'm not
very good at i'm not that closely
involved with the council and
although i'll defend the council i'm not
i'm not on the membership committees or
the board but i think there's a
membership committee that elects a
couple of dozen people a year you get
nominated by other people and anybody
who deals in foreign affairs can be a
member is no there's no exclusion no
litmus test of philosophy it's not
liberal or conservative or republican or
democrat and if you're put up for
membership i think the only real
criteria is have you had any involvement
either as a businessman a lawyer or a
journalist in dealing or a government
official or an academic in dealing with
foreign affairs since i was a journalist
i dealt in foreign affairs some and uh
you know i mean i know george bush was a
member and he felt he had to resign
because so many people raised it as a
criticism but i think it goes from you
know william buckley to daniel ellsberg
who have probably all been members of
the council trilateral commission
trilateral commission is far more elite
uh and uh and harder to get into my
definition of elite and hard to get into
is that nobody would ever invite me to
be in it
uh
it's people who are it's called
trilateral because they're interested in
japan europe and the united states the
relationship between the three major
economic powers
also
somewhat funded and started by the
rockefellers were large contributors to
help start this thing it's mainly for
international businessmen and people who
deal in
japanese european and
american relations
and
it doesn't have a particular clubhouse
or anything or some house where people
go but they have meetings uh i don't
know i think maybe two or three times a
year i'm not particularly sure
and the bilderberg group yeah that's uh
kissinger was very involved in the
bilderberg group and as i say it's not
something that i've ever been asked to
join and so i don't have any i'd write
about it in the book and what i know
about is what people who members have
told me
it first met in the hotel bilderberg i
think in holland
about 30 40 years ago george ball was
one of the founders he was a great
international lawyer and diplomat the
united states
and there were two european founders and
it's there to promote good
european-american relations
and especially for the east coast
foreign policy establishment types
including some who are in the council on
foreign relations uh the bilderberg
group serves as a way to form
connections with similar people in
europe
and i think they meet at least once a
year
the last meeting was a year or so ago on
long island as a matter of fact it's not
usually in the united states but last
year it was
and it's
a group of people from all over europe
and the united states who come together
to discuss foreign affairs
the bohemian club bohemian grove that's
more of a social organization it's a
club in california where people go
mainly in the summertime they have camps
and they sort of cots and sort of
outdoor camp type things where grown men
usually wealthy industrialists and
others get together for a week or so of
discussions lectures
putting on skits singing
and probably a lot of drinking and just
having a good time and
it's uh
president reagan president ford george
schultz henry kissinger a lot of people
have been members of the bohemian grove
how about the metropolitan club here in
washington i don't know much about that
you right you wrote that a lot of
meetings were held there and and it
seemed to weave in and out of your book
yeah it's a good gentleman's uh club uh
for
members of the washington establishment
especially for old time washingtonians
not the people who rotate in and out for
one administration but for example
joseph alsop and people like that who
were the distinguished uh
washington establishment were generally
members of the metropolitan club one of
your chapter heads has to do with
georgetown and washington why did you
write about georgetown and henry
kissinger
well kissinger became our first
celebrity statesman or celebrity
diplomat
and he realized that in order to be
popular in the nixon administration not
popular with president nixon who hated
this but be popular with the press and
all he had to be on the georgetown party
circuit so he loved going and he was the
toast of the town he was the most
eagerly sought dinner guest in
georgetown but all the
georgetown
social circuit including
you know katherine graham to joseph
kraft joseph alsop the braden's
that crowd
he was the toast of their dinner tables
and
and it helped him form good
relationships with say the columnists
people you know newspaper columnists
tv commentators
as well as the real opinion makers
because that as you know
being here in washington is the way a
lot of the wheels are greased in
washington is that people may want to
leak a little something about how a
particular person in government is not
doing very well or has some crazy theory
and the way to do it is to tell the tale
at a dinner party and within
maybe uh six hours it spread all over
washington kissinger was a master at
going to the dinner parties cultivating
the commentators and getting a good
press as a result
you right
chosen here that you had interviews with
susan mary alsop you had an interview
with polly kraft with katherine graham
a lot of these interviews have to do
with the stories of how henry kissner
used to try to manipulate their husbands
or how to try to manipulate catherine
graham um what did tell the story about
joe craft and uh
writing something and he he wasn't he
tried to call him oh yeah well kraft
wrote kraft was somewhat of a liberal
columnist and although he was a friend
of kissinger's he was one of the few
people who understood an essential truth
about henry kissinger which is that the
way to get his attention was not to try
to curry favor with him but to criticize
some of his policies because kissinger
would then try to engage and want to
convince you otherwise and he almost had
more respect for people who stood up and
challenged him well craft wrote a column
i think about cambodia
and about how bad the cambodian policy
was kissinger was furious and uh instead
of cutting craft off and not giving him
any more
dr craft was in bed
his wife was saying i'm sorry i'm not
going to wake him up he doesn't want to
wake up he you can talk about it in the
morning getting to call back in finally
the doorbell rings and there's henry
kissinger standing on the doorstep in
georgetown saying he has to see joseph
craft to
convince him and kraft comes down in his
robe and they sit up late into the night
with kissinger trying to explain
cambodia to him
did you leave the impression that he
invented the background the deep
background the not-for-attribution the
well he was the one who played that game
quite a bit he loved dealing with the
press and
most of the time he would talk not for
quotation in other words he wouldn't
talk on the record but instead of just
talking off the record which means the
stuff can't be used he was the one who
perfected the notion of having different
grades such as he would talk on
background which meant whatever he said
could be used but it couldn't be
directly quoted to henry kissinger and
that's how the phrase a senior
administration official or a senior
white house official was often used when
kissinger said something and then he'd
sometimes talk on deep background which
meant nothing could be really quoted at
all but the reporter could use the
information but not attribute it in any
way so he had all those rules every now
and then it would get too complicated
once he was
talking on deep background about how
nixon might cancel a summit meeting with
the soviet union
if something didn't happen he was
pushing the soviets to do something they
hadn't even consulted with nixon on this
nixon was outraged when this came out
but worse yet it was such a big piece of
news the washington post decided it
couldn't just keep it on deep background
couldn't say according to those familiar
with the administration's thinking the
summit might be canceled they decided to
go ahead and say henry kissinger says
this
so that caused a great bit of hand
ringing and kissinger quit giving
background briefings especially to the
post there was a lot of discussion
finally the post was brought back into
the ranch and they started going to the
background briefings again and started
keeping him on background but he was the
one who could i mean as one reporter
said he played the press like a fiddle
because he was so
interesting he was so expansive he was
so great at explaining foreign policy
that reporters naturally gravitated
towards him as a source throughout your
book you define it you use the word
obnoxious and arrogant and you say that
he mistreated secretaries and uh you
have a whole chapter on wiretaps and how
he wiretapped his friends and his
colleagues and all that it's all that
true yeah well i mean i'm quoting people
i don't think on my own accord i would
ever call them that but they're people
who tell the tales and sure he had an
enormous temper he was very thin-skinned
and les gelp who's now columnist with
the new york times but who was a student
of kissinger's at harvard worked a
little bit with kissinger in government
went in and out of government around the
time kissinger was he said that
kissinger was the typical product of an
authoritarian background kissinger being
from nazi germany he said he was
he was
a devious with his peers obsequious to
his superiors and domineering towards
his subordinates and that's the aspect
of kissinger's personality i found very
unattractive he was a
he was always playing people off against
each other
denigrating people talking about people
behind their backs he wasn't
necessarily
outright duplicitous saying one thing to
one side and one thing to the other side
another thing to the other side but he
came close he would allow one side to
believe the doves or the liberals that
he agreed with them and then he go talk
to conservatives and hawks he let them
feel that he agreed with that side so he
got a reputation for being duplicitous
why do people put up with him
well he was charming he was brilliant he
was powerful and a lot of people didn't
they got very mad at him he made a lot
of enemies he was the most venerated and
most respected secretary of state in
many ways but he was also the most hated
secretary of state and if you read the
book
everybody i talked to talked on the
record because i didn't want people to
denigrate kissinger
under the cloak of anonymity so of all
the 150 people you talked about they're
all cited by name footnote and stuff but
he didn't get away with it in fact
somebody once said he was not really
that masterful of a liar because he was
male or masterful he wouldn't have such
a reputation for being one uh he kept
getting caught at it but you know you
look at what james schlesinger says
about the kissinger in the book i mean
he says that you know i think one of his
quotes was most people when they lie
look to shame but when henry kissinger
lies
he does it as a matter of his own nature
because it's like an arab asks to him or
helmut sonnenfeld who worked for
kissinger who said you know kissinger
doesn't lie because it's in his interest
he lies because it's in his nature so
you know he didn't get kissenger did not
get away with it that much because even
people who sort of liked him even people
who worked with him even people who
respected his mind
still
were upset
and would talk on the record about his
what they considered to be his devious
personality you though said and i don't
know where it is that five people would
not allow you to quote them what did you
do with all that information yeah i did
out of the 150 some odd people i
interviewed there were five who wanted
to stay off the record
i did not use any allegations they made
they weren't that important they were
not
major characters in the book what
happened was maybe 50 people talked to
me on background or off the record but i
went back to all 50 of them and said
look everybody else is talking on the
record
if you want to say this about kissinger
enough time has passed
you should be able to say it on the
record you should be willing to come
right out and say it and as i say out of
those 50 people about 45 said well yes
you can use what i said
and use me as a source five said no and
it wasn't really necessary to use
any allegations they made or anonymous
quotes they made
i used the information in other ways by
say going to other people and trying to
verify through people who would talk on
the record in one of the footnotes i
read that uh you've been at timeout you
read the footnotes that's really
been at time magazine since 1978. uh
yeah i joined time in 1978. uh i had
worked on the sunday times of london
before then and also the new orleans
states item times pick you new orleans
being my hometown new orleans is home
yeah where did you go to school
i went to newman in new orleans and then
harvard and then oxford and england for
graduate work can you remember when you
first got interested in being a writer
oh i studied philosophy at oxford and
when i finished i realized that there
was not much of a need for philosophers
in this world you couldn't hang out a
shingle and
and sort of make a living as a
consulting philosopher
i was interested in journalism i was
interested in history and it seemed like
a good thing to do
after i graduated i as i say worked for
the sunday times in london which was a
very interesting paper and then finally
for the paper in new orleans what your
parents do
my parents are my father's an engineer
and an architect in new orleans and um
my mother was a real estate agent for a
while nicholas lemon from new orleans
nick and i just spent i spent a week
with nick uh just this past week in new
orleans his parents and my parents and
his grandparents and my parents have
been friends for
generations and he's a he's one of the
truly great scholars to come out of new
orleans his book is great who got you
interested in history
uh i was asked this question in new
orleans a week or so ago and i mentioned
my high school history teacher because
he was in the audience so i guess
since this is a nationwide show i better
talk about my high school history
teacher
i was always interested in
american history in particular
andrew jackson
all the way through and american foreign
policy
and i studied history at harvard did
some of it at oxford along with
philosophy
and it's a good outlet when you're
interested about the world to look back
and say and not just history but i
mentioned personalities in history as
was kissinger because syndra went to
harvard he wrote his undergraduate
thesis on kant and then on meadow nick
and then he wrote about bismarck he
wrote napoleon lord casselry the british
foreign minister
all these 19th century statesmen and he
was very very interested
and believed in the role that
personality plays in affecting history
because you know one great school of
historical thought in the past
uh generation has downplayed the role
that people and personalities play and
played up economic forces or other
things kissinger was a true believer in
the role that personalities play in fact
during the middle east shuttles he said
i quoted in the book he said well you
know when i was a professor i thought
great forces shaped history now that i'm
up close to it i see where the
difference personalities make and so i
was always interested in the
personalities of history kissinger being
the most uh the larger-than-life
personality you dedicate this book to
betsy who is worthy of her name my
mother died about six years ago and the
wise man was dedicated to her among
other people and her name was betsy and
shortly about two and a half years ago
we had a daughter named betsy named
after my mother and she's a great
daughter and so she's worthy of her name
because she looks like acts like and has
the same intelligence and spunk that my
mother did in fact i remember you
devoted a whole paragraph to your
daughter well i had to she's a demanding
uh two-year-old like all two years old i
think i paraphrased the pg woodhouse and
i said i wanted to dedicate the book to
my daughter betsy without whose
invaluable help it would have been
written in half the time
because it would she would sit there on
my lap and play with the keyboard while
i typed and you said you started the
book seven years ago um
at what point during
seven years did you spend the most
time on it what was it
well up until 1988 i was working as a
national editor at time
and that was the as you know the 88
campaign the bush dukakis campaign so
most of my energies and focus of my
attention was time magazine and our
political coverage
after that i took a little bit of time
off i mean during that period i was
doing a lot of the interviews because i
love talking about kissinger and it's
easy to do the interviews all you have
to do is say henry kissinger to most
people and they'll tell you a lot of
stories i mean you just push the button
but then after the election i became
just a writer at time for a while so i
had more time to pursue kissinger and
then eventually uh i guess during that
period when c-span visited time magazine
and broadcast our meetings
for better or worse i was on leave of
absence for
six or eight months doing the writing of
the book
i've got here
the
new york times book review
by theodore draper and this was
september the 6th
the reason i hold it up is that
not only did you get the front cover of
the book review for sunday but five full
pages almost were devoted to this review
have you ever seen one that big no i
think it's the longest they've ever done
and um i guess i'm flattered although i
fear people who said to me uh gee i
spent all weekend reading that book
review now i don't have to buy the book
and i'd say no no no that's not you
should read the book
but uh so you sort of feel that but it's
a very interesting review theodore
draper is a great scholar as you know uh
and interestingly enough was uh
kissinger
after he immigrated to america from
germany from bavaria he joined the us
army
the 84th infantry division and went back
to germany as part of the
counterintelligence corps of that
division
during the occupation of germany right
at the end of world war ii interestingly
enough theodore draper was also in that
division and was a historian of that
division is it true that the new york
times does not have someone review a
book of somebody they know
i guess so i've never met the draper i
mean i've never seen them what'd you
think of the review oh i thought it was
uh very interesting it was certainly
very favorable so i like that part of it
he comes out like anybody who's going to
write about a kissinger biography he has
his own opinions on kissinger his own
analysis that i found interesting but
that is really uh it's it's him speaking
for himself as well as
uh reviewing the book but i found that
you know he's a person who's thought
about kissing he's very critical of
kissinger i think perhaps a little bit
more i think
i think my book is balanced and not
quite as critical as theodore draper is
of kissinger
but uh
i was uh very flattered that somebody of
that stature would write about the book
for such a you know for the longest
review in the new york times do you have
any idea why they devoted so much space
to no i've been i don't know who to ask
i if i run into uh theodore draper i'll
ask him
barth healy writes a little sidebar on
you
um
and he says
to a reader who has just finished the
893 pages of kissinger the author 40
years old sandy hared boyishly anxious
about his image
seems to have seems to have taken on
some of his subjects characteristics i
was very eager to try to explain certain
things and you know you get into
and it is like kissinger i mean
kissinger is a man who
when you ask him about things he's
convinced that you're not going to
understand them and that he's got to get
to to understand what he did in cambodia
what he did in the middle east why he
had to cut the state department out of
certain things and he has sort of that
eager quality to make you understand and
i guess like any biograph
biographer you
can see some of yourself
in the person you're writing about
he ends it with a
couple of sentences i want to ask you
about mr isakson's own extensive records
are in boxes in his basement he does not
expect anyone ever to ask for them
i don't know why he said that he uh he
asked where kissinger's papers were i
said the national archives has some of
the official ones the library of
congress has the private papers that
sort of thing and to me it's very
important if you're going to do a
biography of this nature to go to the
documents the written records the
archives and also do the interviews
because you have to triangulate some of
the memos are misleading but of course
people's memories may be faulty so if
you have both the memos and the memories
you can put things together
and so i spent a lot of time tracking
down people's papers
and
tracking down not only kissingers but
people who work for kissinger who tend
to have their papers in their own
basements or you know they haven't done
anything with the papers yet but they've
kept memos of conversations they had
with henry kissinger
and so uh he just asked me where i kept
my papers and i said i guess they're
still in my basement and he asked me
whether i was going to donate them to
some library and it
never occurred to me that any library
would ask for all my papers so i said i
didn't expect anybody to ask for them
but if anybody wants them
you know
be happy to donate them anywhere
you say you took shorthand on all the
notes
did you
use a tape recorder anywhere
i don't think i used a tape recorder um
maybe occasionally but it it's far
easier to do shorthand and if you if you
tape record a five hour interview
then you have to go back and you have to
spend 10 hours
transcribing it
and then what you have is shorthand
notes of
you know but you spend a whole extra day
doing that also
to me the act of transcribing or the act
of taking notes
taking shorthand writing down what
people say allows me to focus a little
bit better on what they're saying and in
some ways gives me a little bit more
time to formulate a question because you
can
you know you can use your notes as a
shield as a way and it also
it's just a way to keep an interview
more professional i find and it gives
you a better written record of it as
opposed to thousands and thousands of
tapes you know somewhere that you can
never really find what you need when you
to go through playing tape after tape to
try to find what you want where did you
find win then two
um president two the former president of
south vietnam
had gone into exile in england when i
was first starting this book and i
tracked him down there
i really wanted him to talk because he
was one of these people who's very
deceived by kissinger kissinger secretly
negotiated the
vietnamese peace treaty without fully
consulting with the president of south
vietnam who was our ally there
and i knew he had strong feelings and he
had never talked about them so i tracked
him down
and then he came over to uh
newton center
right outside of boston massachusetts
where he has some relatives and i think
he kept it pretty secret where he was he
would have still somebody who could
cause controversy or
there are people who fought in vietnam
who have strong opinions about president
two
so i promise i wouldn't say exactly
where he was but at the times when i was
meeting with him it was either in the
city of boston
where he would come in town to meet or
nearby and i think he was living
or staying
in near newton in newton center what's
he like now he's a very dignified person
not bitter in the least
strong memories feels that he was
betrayed by the u.s and vietnam
feels very strongly about vietnam now
that now that the cold war is over
uh it's time for a democratic government
to return to vietnam
he feels that more american force could
have won the war
he also feels that america was trying to
deceive him and cut and run
and that
we never had any intention of winning
the war i think to some extent that's
true but what i don't think he fully
grasps is that america could not win the
war for him
south vietnamese could have won the war
i mean if the war was going to be won it
had to be won by the south vietnamese
perhaps with american help certainly
with american support
but
you're never going to be able to win at
a bargaining table
what your allies in place can't win on
the battlefield it's a rule of
that bismarck understood maternity
understood and i'm sure every other
scholar of warfare understood and if the
south vietnamese were not able to hold
their own against the north vietnamese
on the battlefield or in the hearts and
minds of the people of south vietnam
then there was no way the united states
or kissinger could negotiate at the
bargaining table something that couldn't
be won on the battlefield of all these
150 interviews that you had and you list
here which one was the hardest which
person was the hardest to find yeah
president too i guess
and hardest to convince to give me an
interview was richard nixon
it was remarkably easy to track most of
these people down
partly because there's a network they've
all worked with each other and one would
say you've got to you know if i talked
to melvin laird he'd say we have to talk
to so-and-so and i talked to james
schlesinger who was secretary of defense
he said you must talk to so and so uh i
get oh i guess the hardest ones now that
i think about it though were the
childhood friends for example there's a
guy named
menachem leon probably in that list
there
kissinger's best friend when they were
seven years old they sat on benches next
to each other alphabetically kissinger
leon in germany and yeah in the
israelite rail school in germany in
firth germany the town where they were
raised
they studied uh the torah together
uh and menachem leon's father was a
uh almost a surrogate father in a way to
kissinger just like often people have
with their best friend's father
and uh he was very important to talk to
but when he was a child he was not named
menachem that's the name he took when he
went to israel his name was heinz as was
henry kissinger they were both heinzes
and so i knew that there was this person
heinz leon and many other people like
that
and he lived in jerusalem
and i finally was able to track him down
as menachem leon who is a uh
through a uh professional society for
the society he
works in a certain i can't even remember
the profession now i think um did you go
see him there
no i did not see him in jerusalem i took
him on the phone a bit and then he came
through like a lot of people you know
you see them when they're traveling to
new york or other places likewise uh
a lot of the childhood friends are now
in chicago
some are in washington heights but the
best way was
most people from most of the jews from
first germany when they escaped right
before the nazi holocaust
came to washington heights which is in
manhattan the upper part of manhattan
and they all settled within a four or
five block area
paula kissinger henry kissinger's mother
still lives in the apartment there
and i'd go up there
i think she's about 93
and i'd go up there
and just sitting in the park there would
be people who would say oh yes we knew
kissinger when he was a young boy in
germany and they would point out or give
me the numbers of various other people
to call
and they'd say oh you have to call
walter oppenheimer who by the way is in
that picture
uh next to uh
if i can point to it here
uh that's henry kissinger in the army
that's his first wife ann fleischer and
that's ann fleischer's previous
boyfriend who was a friend of
kissinger's from
the bavarian region of germany walter
oppenheimer i think i tracked him down
in providence rhode island where he's
now a jeweler if i remember correctly
but just hanging around in washington
heights i'd get leads on where various
people from that wave of immigration was
let me ask you and we're running out of
time um
after you've finished this book seven
years working on thinking about and
probably thinking more longer than about
henry kissinger
is this on this man on balance was he
good for the united states i think that
the
foreign policy he was able to develop a
balance
an opening towards the soviet union
balancing it off with china allowing
america to have a new diplomatic role in
the middle east through his shuttles
helped preserve
america's role in the world and its
influence in the world after vietnam
when as you'll recall there was a great
sense of retreat after vietnam almost a
neo-isolationism and he helped preserve
our influence in the world that was
important because it helped stand up to
the soviet threat stand up to the spread
of communism and i think get some of the
credit
and who knows how historians will
apportion all of the credit
for
letting the internal contradictions of
the soviet system work themselves out
and allow communism to collapse however
why i think his legacy in the long run
was not as lasting as it could have been
and in many ways detrimental was that he
had to feel for power in this world but
he didn't have a feel for the strength
that comes from the openness and the
values of our system and if anything won
the cold war it was an appreciation
around the world for american values for
individual rights for the openness of
our system all sorts of things that
kissinger with his secretive diplomacy
did not fully appreciate so i think the
structures were masterful as i say at
the end of the book but in some ways
they were built on a foundation of
bricks without straw they tended to
crumble after a while because of the
backlash against dayton the backlash
against a lot of what he did
the unwillingness to support the vietnam
agreement
largely because it was done without
a good feel for the openness and values
of our democratic institutions
this is the cover of the book
kissinger a biography by walter isaacson
thank you very much hey thank you brian
thanks a lot for having me
[Music]
next week on booknotes our guest will be
former harvard university law professor
derek bell
he'll join us to discuss his book faces
at the bottom of the well the permanence
of racism
that's book notes next sunday night at
eight and eleven p